LAW GRAD TED CRUZ,
CONSTITUTIONAL EXPERT, APPEARED
TO GET THE SHORT END OF A DEBATE
ON VOTING RIGHTS DURING A
JUDICIARY HEARING.
HE ASKED USC LAW PROFESSOR
TOLSON WHETHER SHE THINKS VOTER
I.D. LAWS ARE RACIST.
HERE'S PART OF THE EXCHANGE.
>> SO IT DEPENDS.
ONE THING WE HAVE TO STOP DOING
IS VEETING OWL VOTER I.D. LAWS
THE SAME.
>> YOUR ANSWER -- I WANT TO MOVE
QUICKLY.
IT DEPENDS IS YOUR ANSWER?
>> YES.
>> SO WHAT VOTER I.D. LAWS ARE
RACIST?
>> APOLOGIES, MR. CRUZ.
YOUR STATE OF TEXAS, PERHAPS.
>> OKAY.
SO YOU THINK THE ENTIRE STATE OF
TEXAS IS RACIST.
WHAT ABOUT REQUIRING AN I.D. TO
VOTE IS RACIST?
>> I THINK IT'S REDUCTIVE.
NOT THE ENTIRE STATE OF TEXAS --
>> YOU SAID MY STATE OF TEXAS.
YOU TELL ME --
>> ABSOLUTELY.
SO THE FACT THAT THE VOTER I.D.
LAW WAS PUT INTO PLACE TO
DIMINISH THE POLITICAL POWER OF
LATINOS WITH RACE AS --
>> YOU ARE INSERTING THAT.
WHAT IS YOUR EVIDENCE?
>> THE FEDERAL DISTRICT COURT
THAT FIRST RESOLVED THE
CONSTITUTIONALITY OF TEXAS'
VOTER I.D. LAW.
>> YOUR VIEW IS VOTER I.D. LAWS
ARE RACIST.
HOW ABOUT YOU, MR. YANG?
>> I AGREE.
VOTER I.D. LAWS CAN BE RACIST.
>> THERE ARE SOME VOTER I.D.
LAWS THAT ARE RACIALLY
DISCRIMINATORY IN INTENT.
>> NOW, LET'S MOVE PAST THE
SHAME OF CRUZ PLAYING
CRUZ PLAYING SUCH A SILLY GAME,
OH, YOU CALLED THE WHOLE STATE
RACIST.
NO, THE PROFESSOR DIDN'T, SHE
SAID IN RESPONSE TO HIS QUESTION
ABOUT WHAT LAWS, YOUR STATE'S
LAW.
IT'S A DIRTY TRICK BECAUSE IT'S
NOT ABOUT THE LAW EVEN FOR A
LEGAL EXPERT BECAUSE IT'S ABOUT
SOMETHING ELSE.
WHAT?
LET'S BRING IN MICHAEL ERIC
DYSON, AUTHOR OF "ENTERTAINING
RACE."
WELCOME BACK TO PRIME TIME.
>> THANK YOU, MY FRIEND.
IT'S GREAT TO BE HERE.
>> WHAT IS YOUR DIAGNOSIS OF THE
DEBATE?
>> WELL, IT WAS A SHE NAN BEGAN,
IT WAS A SLEIGHT OF HAND.
SENATOR CRUZ KNOWS THIS IS NOT
ABOUT THE WHOLE STATE OF TEXAS
BEING RACIST.
IT'S ABOUT THE FACT THAT YOU CAN
HAVE A CONCEALED LICENSE I.D.
THAT WILL SUFFICIENTLY QUALIFY
YOU TO GET A VOTING RIGHTS -- TO
HAVE YOUR VOTING RIGHTS AND TO
EXERCISE THEM, BUT YOU CAN'T USE
YOUR STATE -- YOUR STUDENT I.D.
SO WE KNOW IN NORTH CAROLINA,
FOR INSTANCE, UNTIL RECENTLY
WHEN THAT LAW WAS STRUCK DOWN
THAT YOU COULDN'T -- YOU
COULDN'T USE YOUR PUBLIC
ASSISTANCE I.D. OR YOU COULDN'T
USE YOUR STATE EMPLOYEE I.D.,
WHICH ARE DISPROPORTIONATELY
HELD BY BLACK PEOPLE.
IN WISCONSIN UNTIL RECENTLY --
WELL, NOW THEY ACCEPT MILITARY,
YOU KNOW, LIVE ENROLLED ACTIVE
MILITARY I.D. BUT NOT THE
VETERANS' I.D.
SO THE DISPROPORTIONATE IMPACT
ON BLACK PEOPLE AND BROWN PEOPLE
IS SUFFICIENT.
THEN WHEN YOU ADD IN THE FACT
THAT IT TAKES A LOT OF MONEY TO
GET THE UNDERLYING DOCUMENTS.
THE REASON A LOT OF BLACK FOLK
DON'T HAVE STATE ISSUED I.D.s,
25% OF BLACK VOTERS DON'T HAVE
GOVERNMENT I.D.s COMPARED TO
ONLY 8% OF WHITE PEOPLE.
WHY?
BECAUSE THE UNDERLYING DOCUMENTS
ARE HARD TO GET.
THEN TRYING TO GET THEM AS A
BLACK OR BROWN PERSON LIVING IN
RURAL AREAS, TRYING TO GO TO
DOCUMENT CENTERS, PAYING THE
FEES ANYWHERE FROM 75 TO $175.
THAT DOESN'T SOUND A LOT FOR
PEOPLE WHO ARE UPPER CLASS, BUT
PEOPLE STRUGGLING EVERY DAY
TRYING TO MAKE ENDS MEET, THIS
IS A DELETERIOUS IMPACT ON THEM.
EVEN IF YOU EXCLUDE INTENT, THE
DISPROPORTIONATE CONSEQUENCE ON
BLACK AND BROWN VOTERS AND OTHER
ABLED, DISABLED VOTERS ADDED IN,
YOU'VE GOT A NASTY AFFAIR ON
YOUR HANDS.
>> HERE'S THE PROBLEM, POLLS OF
POPULARITY, IF YOU LOOK AT
WHETHER OR NOT PEOPLE WANT VOTER
I.D., LET'S SAY YOU TAKE THE
MONMOUTH POLL WHICH WE RESPECT
AS A SOURCE, FROM JUNE, 80%
SUPPORT.
THERE'S ANOTHER POLL THAT SHOWS
THAT THE NUMBER IS SIMILAR EVEN
WITH NON-WHITE VOTERS, 80, 84%.
SO IF EVERYBODY WANTS IT, WHY
FIGHT AGAINST IT?
>> WELL, LOOK AT WHAT TED CRUZ
DID TODAY.
IF YOU'RE TRYING TO SET IT UP
WITH DISINGENUOUS INTENT AND
YOU'RE DISHONEST, PEOPLE ARE
GOING TO GO THAT'S HORRIBLE.
WHEN YOU BREAK IT DOWN FOR
PEOPLE AND YOU BEGIN TO ASK THEM
OTHER QUESTIONS, DO YOU THINK
IT'S FAIR FOR PEOPLE TO HAVE TO
GO A CERTAIN DISTANCE WHEN THEY
HAVE OTHER VALID FORMS OF I.D.
DO YOU THINK IT'S IMPORTANT THAT
PEOPLE WHO HAVE RESPECT FOR THE
LAW AND HAVE CERTAIN ISSUED
I.D.s AND NOT OTHERS THAT THEY
SHOULD BE SOMEHOW DISQUALIFIED
THE ANSWER IS NO.
IT DEPENDS ON HOW THE POLLS ASK
THE QUESTIONS.
LET'S ADMIT IT, WHEN MARTIN
LUTHER KING JR. WAS FIGHTING FOR
CIVIL RIGHTS IN THIS COUNTRY,
THE POLLS BEGAN TO CATCH UP TO
WHERE THE CONSCIENCE OF THE
NATION WAS.
POLLS REGISTER OUR CONTEMPORARY
OPINION THAT SHOULD BE SHAPED
AND MOLDED ACCORDING TO THE
PRINCIPLES AND PRACTICES OF
DEMOCRACY THAT WE CLAIM TO
EMBRACE.
>> HOW DANGEROUS IS IT FOR THE
DEMOCRATS IF THEY DO NOT PASS
THE VOTING RIGHTS BILL THAT IS
BEFORE THEM?
>> IT IS AWFUL DARN DANGEROUS.
WE GOT TO STAND UP.
DON'T BE FECKLESS OR SPINELESS.
STAND UP AND SAY THIS IS WRONG.
WE KNOW THIS IS WRONG.
WE KNOW THAT THE PEOPLE ARE
DOING THIS, YOU KNOW, RHETORICAL
LEDGER DOMAIN AS TED CRUZ WAS
DOING TODAY, THE SLEIGHT OF
HAND.
YOU KNOW DARN WELL THIS STUFF
DOES NOT HAVE GOOD INTENTIONS.
IT WAS GOOD ENOUGH TO ELECT OLD
MAN BUSH, IT WAS GOOD ENOUGH TO
ELECT YOUNG MAN BUSH, BUT ALL OF
A SUDDEN THERE NEEDS TO BE VAST
REFORM WHEN DEMOCRATIC POWER
BEGAN TO ASSERT ITSELF.
THIS IS NOT ABOUT THE LAW.
THIS IS NOT ABOUT LEGAL
PROCEDURE.
THIS IS NOT ABOUT EVEN THE
OSTENSIBLE MESS-UPS OF THE
SYSTEM, THE HICCUPS AND SO ON.
THIS IS ABOUT A NAKED POWER GRAB
AND THE DEMOCRATS HAVE TO FIND
THEIR VOIC